Okay, hopefully you didn't find that too hard.
Let's take the name in order. Deoxy here
deoxy, what do you think that means? Is
probably missing an oxygen. So the deoxy part
of a name for DNA describes this part
of the chemistry. The next part, ribo, indicates
that there's a ribose sugar as part of
the deoxy nucleotide. This is the sugar molecule
called a ribose sugar. So that's what
the ribo represents in the name. Nucleic was
probably the toughest one if you couldn't figure
it out. Actually represents the nitrogenous base here
or the nucleic acid. This means that it's
found in the nucleus. And then the last
bit, actually over here, the acid Is an
artifact from this, what we call a phosphate
group right here. Under some conditions when
DNA was first isolated, it actually had acidic
properties, and it is because of the nature of this group right here. So you can
see that the name, deoxyribonucleic acid, which
is the long form for the abbreviation DNA
Actually, it's just describing the chemistry of missing
an oxygen, being part of a ribose sugar,
containing a nitrogenous base, that can be found in the nucleus.
And, also containing a group that can be acidic under certain conditions.